If you ever get to travel to China or even go to your local Chinese restaurant,...
...you'll want to know a little about Chinese mealtime manners...
...and a few basics of chopstick use.
It is bad manners to tap chopsticks on the edge of your bowl.
At one time, beggars made this sort of noise to attract attention.
It is impolite to spear food with a chopstick.
Anything too difficult to be handled with chopsticks is usually eaten with a spoon.
It is considered bad manners to point chopsticks toward others seated at the table.
Chopsticks should not be left vertically stuck into a bowl of rice...
...because it looks like the ritual of incense burning...
...that symbolizes feeding the dead and death, in general.
Be careful not to dig or search through your food for something in particular.
This is sometimes known as digging one's grave or grave digging...
...and is extremely impolite.
Putting your chopsticks at the top of the bowl means "I've finished."
Putting your chopsticks on the side of your bowl or on a chopstick stand...
...means that you're just taking a break from eating.
Remember to chew with your mouth closed.
Finish your personal rice bowl and don't burp.
In China, you should try what you are offered,...
...but don't feel like you have to finish it all.
If the plates are completely clean at the end of a meal,...
...your host might feel that they haven't given you enough to eat.
It's normal to hold the rice bowl up to your mouth...
...and use chopsticks to push or scoop the rice into your mouth.